PEACE PRIZE
I'LL ELO
>>> FIRST, HER
IN AMERICATH TN THE SECTORS, WK
INSIGHTS INTO THE WORLD.OUND
AND WHEN THE PERN SPKIVIOUSLATI.
SO WHEN SOMEONE AS S STAGGERING
INN MUSK,
INFORMATION ABS  CAM EN ISFOED
R SO IN EXCESSF THE  DBECAUS
HISENSE.
HIF OR CLATLS --
>> I'M LITERALLYG UBSIDIES.
>> SOU
GRAPTEW THE
MENT'SRE
ELECTRONIC VICA LO TFERADES
SOLD00,0 O, A A CROSSE 2018.IOE
IFR USESNIZED LABOR
T.G STATIOE OFSLES
IN THE FR RATES S
RECENTLY PD  ODY BUILDING
ELON MUSK SHOULD BE THE TECHIOIT
MUSK'AVOR, SPACEX AND SOL EVEN
FOR FERAPPT.NERS
YEARSIVED GENERALNCTIANCRAL AND
STATE GOVEMEIOS THE
AC NOW, Y GOT A $465 M
LOANTHE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY,  IEDED SHO
THE  NEVADA GAVE T.25 BILLION T
PACKAGE  BUILD A BRY M AL
KINDS OF S TAX
CREDITS THATD THE
PRODUCTION ANDNSLLNE AND
>> ANDS RGCOURSENT AGENCIES FROM
DEFENSE.E DE
L SUBSIDIES BECAUSE THOSE FOR O
01GY  RF OFL ENERGY SWHIL JUSON
ENERGY IS TH AFTER. CLE ALL SUBS
ELIMINATED, IT IS GREEN
ENERGY THAT WOULD SUFFER THE
MO
NT
REPPEYEEME
CONVENTION WABOUT BUDGETDES NO
CEOVT 30 YEARS,
GOVERNMEKEPAN HAVE BEEN ABLE ODR
DESPITE SUTIONDOESUNDERSWE D
INERE'S REALLY NO
SEG FOR THE NTY ZERO.
MUSK AD TH
BETTE
BU S ALLOW FS AND ROADHANISM
TACKLE OBMEGREEN ENERGY I
PRCOR COMED IN THE 1950sMPUTERP
IT VER THENVESTMENDEs TO
, LOTE